ja und wladimir putin er dreht also
weiter am gashahn um uns zu verunsichern
natürlich laut
bundeswirtschaftsministerium gibt es
keinen technischen grund für diese
liefer reduzierung seit wochen schon
sagen wir hier bei bild dass die
bundesregierung angesichts der
energiekrise und der abhängigkeit von
russlands den ausstieg aus der atomkraft
überdenken muss ideologie darf in dieser
situation nicht gegen vernunft stehen
und siehe da es bewegt sich auf dem
platz
nun doch angeblich will die regierung
gegenüber den eu-partnern jetzt die
bereitschaft zur laufzeitverlängerung
der deutschen akw signalisieren und das
nach langem widerstand besonders von
grünen und spd damit reagiert die ampel
regierung auf die diskussion innerhalb
der eu zum energie notfallplan ein
sogenannter stresstest soll zeigen wie
und ob wir ohne zuschaltung und sah drei
verbliebenen kernkraftwerke über den
winter kommen wir werden bei dem jetzt
ja stattfinden den stresstest auch
natürlich berücksichtigen in welcher
schwierigen lage
sehr viel atomkraftwerke nicht laufen
das werden wir bei uns mit einbeziehen
damit wir im zweifel auch solidarisch
sein können also kommt jetzt doch die
verlängerung der laufzeit die
atomkraftwerke isar 2 emsland und
neckarwestheim 2 soll nach geltendem
recht spätestens am 31 dezember 2022
abgeschaltet werden von dem hintergrund
der energiekrise die sich durch den
russischen angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine zugespitzt hat gibt es seit
monaten eine debatte ob die drei meiler
weiter laufen sollen ob nur für eine
kurze zeit oder sogar für einige jahre
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
betont indes immer wieder dass der
hauptmangel nicht beim strom sondern bei
gas und wärme für die industrie und dass
die atomkraftwerke dafür keine abhilfe
schafften aktuell beträgt der anteil des
erzeugten stroms aus akw gerade mal
sechs prozent
doch was passiert wenn die akw
abgeschaltet sind und die kohle nicht im
geplanten umfang zur verfügung steht
dann gibt es nur noch erdgas zur
stromgewinnung dass wir eigentlich ganz
dringend zum heizen brauchen
ein stresstest soll genau dieses
szenario jetzt unter die lupe nehmen
wird sich in diesem test zeigen dass wir
die akw tatsächlich bitter nötig haben
in so schwierigen entscheidungsprozess
ist es immer wichtig dass man fakten
grundlagen jeden schritt geht ja sind ja
nicht ohne grund aus der atomkraft in
deutschland ausgestiegen jetzt sind wir
in einer notsituation wo wir uns alles
nochmal anschauen deswegen auch das hat
robert habeck mit der umweltministerin
steffi lemke ja zusammen wer bereits
einen ersten test gemacht ob das helfen
würde mit blick auf atomkraftwerke
aktuell ist deutschland im akw europa
ranking auf den hintersten plätzen
zusammen mit den niederlanden die plan
aber bereits neue akw zu bauen
deutschland ist also umgeben von
nachbarn die auf kernkraft setzen ein
ausstieg aus der atomenergie macht das
leben in deutschland also nicht sicherer
nur ein wenig kälter
seit wochen streitet die ampel koalition
also ob die letzten drei atomkraftwerke
über ihr stimmige datum den 31 dezember
2022 hinaus weiter betrieben werden
sollen um eben gas für die
stromproduktion zu sparen die fdp ist
dafür deswegen sprechen wir jetzt mit
alexander biller
bundestagsabgeordneter der fdp schönen
guten tag herr müller
müssen die grünen jetzt endlich
einlenken
die grünen denken ja jetzt ernsthaft
darüber nach und das ist für die grünen
natürlich ein schwerer schritt weil es
liegt in der dna der grünen dass sie
gegen kernkraft sind aber angesichts der
entwicklung müssen den strom den
stromverbrauch sicherstellen im winter
denken die grünen jetzt darüber nach und
ich finde es auch gut heute könnte es in
brüssel zum großen showdown kam wie
wichtig ist da eine entscheidung und wie
sehr stellt das auch die ampel koalition
auf eine zerreißprobe
ja also für uns das kann ist
zerreißprobe die fdp ist ja klar in der
sache und ich sehe aber eine sehr
vernünftige bewegung bei unseren
koalitionspartnern wir wollen gemeinsam
zu erneuerbaren energien kommen das wird
jetzt im winter schwierig und alle
ziehen an einem strang und schauen wie
wir die energieversorgung sichern können
ich bin da ganz zuversichtlich dass die
grünen sich darum angegeben na ja alle
ziehen an einem strang ist fraglich denn
habeck lehnt ja diesen streck betrieb
also die temporäre
laufzeitverlängerungen noch ab weil er
noch die ergebnisse eines neuen
stresstests abwarten will aber kommt die
entscheidung da nicht vielleicht sogar
zu spät
dass strecken der brennelemente da kann
man am einen dreißigsten dezember
entscheiden dass man das streckt das
problem ist ja dass lange jetzt versäumt
wurde neue brennelemente zu bestellen da
sind wir tatsächlich ein bisschen spät
aber auch da bin ich zuversichtlich dass
das funktioniert aber die brennelemente
sind ja nicht am 31 dezember alle auf
einen schlag abgebrannt man kann das ja
weiter laufen lassen und insofern bin
ich da ganz beruhigt sie sind beruhigt
die sind zuversichtlich sagen sie in
fast jeder antwort aber was sagen sie
denn den menschen auch in ihrem
wahlkreis zum beispiel die sagen wir
haben angst vor diesem winter
das ist auch berechtigt das ist noch
nicht das alle gefahr beseitigt ist also
wir müssen alle gas sparen und müssen
uns darauf einstellen dass die
energiepreise mächtig in die höhe gehen
und das sind die herausforderungen für
denken für den kommenden winter und auch
stromausfälle drohen uns natürlich weil
mit jedem kraftwerk was wir vom netz
nimmt steigt natürlich der strompreis
weil es angebot knapper wird und die
sicherheit nimmt ab deswegen ist es so
wichtig und deswegen fordern wir dass
die drei atomkraftwerke ein paar monate
weiterlaufen
alexander müller herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
[Musik]